I'll do it!
Do what, you ask? Have sex!
It's in bad taste you know?
To watch your own son in action.
Funny that you say that.
If you call trembling
with your back turned
while a female makes the move, "Action."
That's probably a first
since the beginning of life.
I have something to tell you.
While you're enjoying your little romance,
There will be those who don't understand,
and try to meddle in your affairs.
They'll give you advice that means
as much as a fortune cookie,
when it's none of their business.
Don't listen to a word.
Celibacy doesn't amount to much.
If you want to be strong, do it!
Do it morning, day and night.
Do it before and after meals.
Do it until you're tired of it.
Do it until you can't any longer.
Just do it until there's nothing left!
What the hell?
Kozue, was it?
Be strong in your pride as a woman!
Let him take you until he tires,
but still leave him wanting.
Be a woman he can't consume.
I congratulate you both.